so I'm basically putting together a
report of the coolest companies in India
that don't have analogs here like for
example there's just company called
about you have you ever heard of Bijou
byj you me why Ju yeah this guy
basically started off as a teacher and
he would teach like essentially test
breath oh you freaking love this I think
I've told you about this before believe
this yeah you like you say that's your
dream this guy he started off as a small
teacher in a town basically and was
doing test prep and then sort of got
bigger and bigger and bigger people
wanted to learn from him to the point
where he was selling out stadiums of
people coming to watch him teach math
and that was when I saw the picture of
the stadium I thought this is that's
right remarkable
then he turned it into an online
learning platform a basically a video
based teaching platform sort of like
Khan Academy but for profit and it's
eight billion dollar company now and
this guy Bijou is sort of one of the
youngest billionaires in India
he's a t-shirt but could turned
billionaire which is very rare and you
know cool product cool company and
there's actually a company in this YC
batch that's trying that's the former
first instructor of Bijoux he's like I
was the face of Bijou because he was in
all the videos and he left to start his
own thing he's like you know here's the
dirty secret about Bee Gees thing it has
very low retention great at making money
great at getting people to sign up but
less than 15% of people stick with the
course as it goes along we're doing this
other way and we're gonna win and
they're in this batch as well so that's
interesting so I would love to ask you
questions about that first I want to
tell you that I'm looking at their
Wikipedia it says they do they're worth
eight billion dollars they do 80 million
in u.s. dollars in sales and then it
says they only have five employees
yeah that's wrong and also they do more
they do more revenue recently there were
over a hundred million I think the last
like I've read something where they were
where they were doing over a hundred
million but so why is it awaiting a 5min
please that'd be amazing why is this big
in India but not America is because
Indians love math and science I mean yes
education is like you know God in India
like you you can be dirt poor in a
village but you'll do anything
educate your kids and you know even
though these or any people in America
you probably have noticed I like you
know their parents are pretty strict
about education you got to get good
grades all that stuff and so Indians are
willing to pay anything for education
and they don't really pay anything for
anything else so entertainment is is
usually lower on the list
although Bollywood does well but like on
a per capita basis where you're gonna
spend your money education is sort of
number one for for Indians so that's the
first part second part is they've such a
huge population so you can take a really
small amount of money from such a huge
number of people and built a very big
company that's the second part how much
bigger is India than America and
population three times so yeah four
times I think it's like one pool I think
is I think it's over 1 billion and USS
300 million I believe so it'd be like
about four times and and of course not
all those people have smartphones not
all those people have money but like you
know it's correct it's India has I sort
of the largest growing middle class so
that's some of the reason why this works
is because people willing to pay for
education and there's so many people
that if you take a few bucks from each
and everybody's willing to pay for this
because it's education that adds up but
you know eight billion is sort of out it
it is outpacing their revenue growth
right so I think the part of it is the
story of what this becomes and there are
sort of defensibility that's probably
why they're valued somewhat higher than
their valid then their revenue would
suggest do you think that that that can
be popular in America oh I think so like
I think Khan Academy is fairly popular
and it's mostly in America no money no
it's just yeah it's a non-profit and
they don't pour money into growth like
these guys do I'm sure these guys are
aggressively trying to grow and using
their pay back to to sort of fund more
growth but yeah I do think like
something like this can work here but
you know we'll see that there might be
other reasons why it doesn't
[Music]